so what i want to do real quick is uh
help people understand
conceptually how uh a decentralized
storage network works and in order to do
that um
maybe we can take two seconds and just
describe a data center so for those that
don't know
uh there are massive computing
facilities all over the world
uh these facilities basically build um
you know the physical structure they put
computers they put storage uh hardware
uh in those facilities and then they
have sales forces that try to go out and
get customers and so
that model um is can be very profitable
if done well
uh but just like any business when you
go to the convenience store
you don't have everyone buying all of
the products in the convenience store at
all times so there's things that are
sitting idle or in this world
uh it is computing power or storage that
is unused
and so this idea of a decentralized
storage network is basically
uh ben the tmat storage has come up with
an incentive mechanism to get
the unused storage to come up for
availability
through a digital means and then people
who need storage can go in and basically
purchase
some of the unused storage at a high
level
accurate and you're the expert here but
is that direction
you're really accurate you know the only
thing i think i would uh sort of
uh clarify is that the drives that
you're using aren't necessarily
in uh in the data centers right so we've
got we've got
some people who have you know we've got
companies who have data centers we've
got universities have data centers
uh you've also got lots of individuals
who are running computers in their
basements
um and all of those you know people in
rural parts of the world that have
you know have a have a disk drive right
all of those can be part of our storage
network and lr
right so we've got um something like 10
000 drives all around the world
or 10 000 people on the world operating
drives in 85 countries
um and you know collectively they've
created a pretty massive storage network
and uh
if you are storing data with us instead
of us storing it on you know one drive
that we control
we sort of split it up into pieces and
we run it across large numbers
by lots of
and so the customer experience from what
i understand is
almost identical to what you would do
with a centralized service right you go
to a website you say hey i need to spin
up some storage
you basically purchased that and uh what
happens from that point through a
centralized in a decentralized service
is different
but for the customer um it's pretty much
exactly the same yeah i mean that was
our intent our intent was to say that
first our customers are concerned we
should just be a
really fast really secure really cheap
um
uh really useful way of doing storage
that doesn't require them to change the
way that they operate
so we've got you know we've got lots of
people doing cool decentralized apps on
us we also have
you know massive numbers of people who
are doing traditional apps on us that
just happen to be doing it down there
got it and so then what is the economic
benefit because that's ultimately the
people who have this
unused storage and they're kind of
offering it up i love the example of
airbnb these are the people who have a
home and they want somebody to come stay
in it right
talk about kind of the economic uh
difference obviously you're competing
with zero
right so they get nothing for their
unused stuff without you right how much
can they make or
how does that work from uh from you you
actually send them somebody to use as a
customer
sure sure so basically uh what
uh if you're a storage node operator or
we call it snows
um you basically you know download some
code onto your onto your drive if you
will
um and for the most part stuff happens
in the background you don't even have to
pay attention right um
uh and again you're not spending
additional
money on power or equipment or people to
do this
um what we do as our economic model is
we
quote prices to our customers and
in essence about 60 percent of what we
make
from our customers goes back to the
network and so as a
storage node operator we quote you a
price based off of how much data you're
storing and how much data you're serving
up
um and you know depending on the size of
your
size of your drive and how much you're
storing um
you know you can make five ten dollars a
month for drives right um so
it's not you know it's not a standalone
business like being a miner
um but for many people it's a great way
of monetizing their energy
and unlike being a miner it doesn't take
a lot of power it doesn't take a lot of
effort it doesn't
you know we we designed this so that it
doesn't take specialized equipment to do
um but this is an incentive model for
excuse me for the rest of us right
um and so as a result we we've got a
really broad group of
storage operators who are happily being
part of this and of course we we
compensate them in our token which is uh
str and so this is something that can be
spun up pretty quickly right if i have
unused storage and i can actually spin
it down as well let's see if i need the
storage or something like that also yeah
it's pretty responsive that's right yeah
so so
um you know now now you're you're sort
of your reputation if you will
is based off of uh things like uptime
um and uh how long you store but if you
are since a data center that
has equipment that sits idle for most of
the year but you need to reclaim it
uh you know around the holiday shoppies
or something like that that's fine
we have we have ways for you to sort of
tell us hey i need to
reclaim my space and you push the data
down